[Música]
momento de hablar de los mercados y las
grandes transacciones que tuvieron el
lugar el día de hoy está conmigo en el
estudio Jorge Hurtado Jorge muy buenas
noches comenzamos hablando de elon musk
que ya llegó oficialmente a las oficinas
de Twitter incluso Santiago cambió su
biografía en la red social para
describirse o para dar entender que ya
está al mando el hombre más rico del
mundo llegó a las oficinas de Twitter en
San Francisco California previo al
viernes cuando se cumple el plazo que un
juez impuso para que compre la red
social los abogados y banqueros ultiman
los detalles de esta compra del año por
un monto de 44 mil millones de dólares
los prestamistas de Wall Street
liderados por Morgan stalin ya se habían
estado preparando en las últimas semanas
para financiar la deuda según informó
bloomberg muchos empleados de Twitter
esperan con ansia las directrices de
Moss como propietario a los posibles
inversores les dijo incluso que planea
recortar el 45% de la planilla que ahora
es de unos 7.500 trabajadores y que
quiere duplicar los ingresos de la red
social en tres años Jorge hablemos ahora
de la empresa meta que es la matriz de
Facebook presentó su informe trimestral
Cómo les fue Bueno nada bien afectada
sobre todo por la inflación que ha
pasado la cuenta o la factura a las
grandes tecnológicas meta presentó sus
provisiones de ingresos para el cuarto
trimestre de entre 30.000 y 32.500
millones de dólares esto hizo que las
acciones se desplomaran más del 12% en
la sesión de hoy los principales
ingresos de meta provienen de la
publicidad pero la incertidumbre
económica global está afectando este
rubro en el tercer trimestre meta
reportó ingresos por 27.700 millones de
dólares los secretos los ingresos netos
cayeron un 54% respecto al mismo
trimestre pero del año anterior y el
beneficio por acción fue de 1,64 dólares
Jorge ya lo mencionamos en el de
noticias que en el Reino Unido el nuevo
gobierno retrasó la presentación de ese
plan económico muy esperado no solo en
el Reino Unido en el mundo entero bueno
el jefe del tesoro del Reino Unido
Jeremy lo pospuso para el próximo 17 de
noviembre esto con el fin de dar al
nuevo Primer Ministro Richi es una clave
oportunidad de opinar sobre las
políticas destinadas a estabilizar las
finanzas del país la declaración
incluirá ahora un presupuesto completo y
un análisis de su impacto en la deuda
pública y el endeudamiento por parte de
la independiente oficina de
responsabilidad presupuestaria el último
plan que fue propuesto por lilithross
que consistía en 116 mil millones de
dólares en recortes de impuestos y
aumento del gasto sin decir como los
pagaría provocó temor por el aumento de
la deuda pública y llevó a la libre
esterlina a la moneda local a mínimos
históricos frente al Dólar los mercados
financieros se han recuperado desde que
home se convirtió en jefe del tesoro y
descartó la mayor parte el plan
económico que había propuesto lestrass
Jorge televidentes estamos a poco menos
de dos semanas de las elecciones de
medio término en Estados Unidos y por
supuesto el tema económico ha pasado a
ser uno de los principales temas de las
campañas de los dos partidos que dicen
allí Bueno sobre todo el tema económico
influye mucho por la inflación anual que
vive Estados Unidos que es la más alta
desde el 1982 el presidente Joe biden
continúa anunciando medidas para hacer
frente a esta situación una cuestión
clave para ganar votos veamos si el
siguiente reporte que nos preparó
nuestro compañero Andrés triviño
una economía golpeada en una época de
campaña por esos días para muchos
estadounidenses el aumento del costo de
vida es el tema principal para estas
elecciones en septiembre la inflación
interanual alcanzó un
8.2%. la más alta desde 1982 crisis una
madre de tres hijos pide ayuda
ni siquiera puedo llevarlos para tomar
un helado solo algo tan pequeño como eso
y siento que nunca voy a recuperar este
tiempo nunca recuperaré este tiempo con
ellos
la inflación Es evidente en los
alimentos los servicios básicos y en los
precios de la vivienda y a dos semanas
de las elecciones de medio término las
cuales definirán si los demócratas
continuarán manteniendo la mayoría en el
congreso o si los republicanos
repuntarán se espera que les pase
factura por lo que este miércoles el
presidente Joe biden anunció que tomará
medidas contra las llamadas tarifas
basura refiriéndose a los sobregiros
cargos ocultos y por Mora entre otros de
bancos y entidades privadas que según su
administración le ahorraría a sus
ciudadanos 3.000 millones de dólares
anuales
hoy mi administración está anunciando
nuevas acciones para reducir el costo de
la vida cotidiana de las familias
estadounidenses para poner más dinero en
los bolsillos de los ciudadanos de clase
trabajadora y de ingresos los medios
para responsabilizar a las grandes
corporaciones Y estos pasos comenzarán
inmediatamente a salvar a las personas
colectivamente
esta misma semana un tribunal Federal
bloqueo temporalmente el plan de alivios
a estudiantes anunciado en agosto una de
las promesas de campaña de baile que
pretendía condenar los pagos de
préstamos universitarios federales en
enero de 2023 y beneficiaría a más de
700 mil personas
bueno así está el panorama Muchas
gracias Jorge a continuación en directo
América el debate
[Música]